ladies and Gentlemen The Last of Us show
is finally debuting and I couldn't be
more thrilled because it's the freaking
Last of Us and I love both those games
but with that in mind I wanted to give
the reject Nation a heads up about the
two different types of uploads you will
be getting from the real rejects over
the course of the next nine weeks uh
it's a it's a little experiment that
we're running but I hope you guys enjoy
it so basically because I love the game
so much I really wanted to experience
this have the reaction commentary
discussion with another person who also
has the same level of enthusiasm for the
games as myself so I'm going to be
covering it with Andrew Gordon those
will be the first reactions that go up
and then a day or two later John and
Tara Erickson two people who have not
played the games will be doing reactions
for the show and so you're going to be
getting a set of reactions from people
who love the game and people a set of
reactions from people who haven't played
the game but don't worry for people who
uh haven't played the game we will make
sure not to be spoiling any possible
things that could happen in future
episodes in my reactions specifically
but either way it should be a funny time
fun experiment